[Musique]
nicolas eu beau jour bienvenue aux abois
ue pour le café politique
vous avez 45 ans élu aux
clayes-sous-bois dans l'opposition dans
l'opposition également au conseil
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines adhérent au
parti socialiste
encore aujourd'hui ou pas on va tout de
suite commencer par ça mais bien situé
et aujourd'hui non je ne suis plus
adhérent au parti socialiste
j'ai rejoint le
mouvement génération point s monté par
benoît hamon il ya quelques quelques
semaines officiellement de cela au mans
et puis de manière plus formelle il ya
déjà quelques quelques temps via le m 17
17 qui était son ancêtre encore il ya
peu
donc voilà non j'ai rejoint ce mouvement
parce qu'il me semble est aujourd'hui
important d'être dans une continuité
notamment par rapport aux politiques par
rapport à la à l'élection présidentielle
qui pour moi a été déclenché aux deux
d'énormément de deux rencontres et de
choses nouvelles en termes
d'accompagnement d'un projet politique
il me semblait nécessaire de continuer
dans cette voie autour de lait auprès de
benoît pour vous aujourd'hui le parti
socialiste est mort finalement sinon je
dis pas ça non je pense que tout parti à
c'est à ces moments de haut ces moments
de bas je n'espère pas en tout cas que
le parti socialiste soit soit mort
j'espère ou précisément plutôt que
puisse se reconstituer une force en tout
cas assez massif de gauche avec
l'ensemble des partis qui qui composent
cette cette grande nébuleuse aujourd'hui
de gauche pour pouvoir justement
mené à terme vers le retour
vous pouvoir et ce de manière concertée
avec l'ensemble de nos
partenaire gauche l'avenir de la gauche
c'est benoît hamon c'est pour
aujourd'hui en dur
attention enfin quand on dit benoît
hamon ce n'est pas benoît hamon en tant
que tel c'est
toutes les réformes car les idées et
tout le projet que que qu'il a défendue
lors de la présidentielle que nous
étions nombreux à défendre autour de lui
et moi si je suis rentré en politique
c'est précisément c'est pour ces pour
anticiper de
tout ce que l'avenir nous réserve ils
n'ont pas gérer les crises alors j'ai
l'impression j'ai le mauvais sentiments
ou depuis quelques années que que nous
nous contentons de gérer les crises et
qu'on ne revient pas anticipé si on
prend juste la question migratoire
nous savons et nous connaissons des
questions sur les problématiques sur les
questions migratoires depuis des années
notamment la question climatique
or nous n'avons jamais pu gérer cette
question là de manière anticipée et nous
gérons depuis 2015 que des crises
aléatoire en fait et moi il me semble
aujourd'hui qu'il est important d'avoir
une anticipation comme nous l'avons
proposé lors de l'élection
présidentielle que benoît hamon
défend et continuera de défendre avec le
mouvement génération point s dans les
mois et les années à venir
aujourd'hui vous défendez ses idées
néanmoins est toujours dans l'opposition
que ce soit dans votre commune que ce
soit à l'agglomération
est ce que cette place dans l'opposition
vous arrivez à vous y faire et à y
trouver vos marquer et à influer quelque
part sur les choix qui sont baissiers
des décisions qui sont prises c'est pas
de position évidente a pas de position
évidente malheureusement c'est toujours
toujours un petit peu frustrant d'être
dans l'opposition que ce soit au sein de
la commune au sein de l'agglomération
parce qu'évidemment nous aurions
énormément de projets différents a amené
avec mes collègues dans l'opposition
cependant ça nous permet aussi de nous
construire et de construire un projet
alternatif en constatant précisément ce
qui ce qui peut aller et ce qui ne va
pas aussi évidemment et tout cela
évidemment à la rencontre des citoyens
parce que la position que nous avons
dans l'opposition nous permet aussi de
rencontre est assez régulièrement des
citoyens qui viennent vers nous pour
nous proposer aussi des projets
alternatifs à ce qui est proposé
aujourd'hui par où la commune où
l'agglomération et qui nous permet aussi
d'enrichir nos idées une éventuelle nous
avons tué le projet pour d'éventuels
échéances électorales futures l'année
combats électoraux vous en avez mené
plusieurs
vous avez perdu ça n'entame en rien
votre motivation votre détermination
non pas du tout non pas du tout parce
que si j'ai perdu évidemment ça on
rappelle où je veux pas forcément
rappeler les contextes a géré voie mais
nous sommes quand même dans un
département difficile la cantonale enfin
la comptonales la départementale par non
et maintenant départemental en 2015
était assez complexe puisque nous étions
à mi-mandat de du président de la
république de l'époque
donc évidemment les élections de mi
mandat sont toujours compliquées que
soient des élections municipales de 2014
ou sections départementales à la suite
pour les élections législatives
s'étaient
ce poste est encore plus avec une vague
qui a suivi l'élection partielle qui est
évident parce qu'évidemment la
mobilisation
la mobilisation des électeurs ne s'est
pas fait 2
manière espérée notamment déjà en terme
de participation
et puis évidemment
la prime la prime au président préside
l'ue était évidente sur cette élection
là non je n'ai pas forcément forcément
mal vécu
en tout cas une autre tâche comme ça se
termine à sion détermination les
décisions futures
en tout cas ma décision de rejoindre
génération progresse
mais c'est vrai que ça forge en tout cas
ça forge sa mort j'ai un caractère et
puis on sait aussi un moment donné qu'il
faut être très affirmée sur ses
positions pour pouvoir continuer à
avancer et ses positions cet engagement
à gauche vous l'avez toujours eu une à
quel moment ça c'est ça s'est révélé
vous avez décidé de franchir le pas de
l'engagement en politique j'ai toujours
eu en fait j'ai toujours eu au sein de
ma ville déjà un engagement citoyen
puisque des très jeunes j'ai participé à
l'élaboration d'actions culturelles
associative donc ça j'ai commencé dès ma
période de jeunes adultes disons et puis
petit à petit je me suis intéressé
évidemment de plus en plus l'action
locale l'action citoyenne je suis
rentrée évidemment en politique par le
biais de l'action locale
et donc là avec toujours ses convictions
de gauche je suis issu d'une famille
traditionnellement de gauche et
mon engagement au sein du parti
socialiste lui a été plus fort mais les
formaliser
il ya maintenant une petite vingtaine
d'années
c'était une époque pour moi qui le coup
ressembler quelque place que nous
vivions la monde la présidentielle
autour de benoît hamon puisque c'est
quand même une époque autour des années
90 est domine ou énormément de projets
politiques publiques en maintenant en
matière de solidarité ont été amenés je
rappelle la 35 heures je rappelle les
cmu etc etc ça a été une fin c'était
pour moi c'est déclencheur de ce que
pouvait amener un militant politique au
sein d'un parti contribue justement au
bien-être de notre de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens via des moyens de solidarité
accrue et une politique dans ce sens-là
telle qu'elle avait été développé par le
gouvernement de lionel jospin à l'époque
mais cet engagement à gauche se traduit
aussi dans votre engagement
professionnel vous avez été chargé de
mission dans une association nationale
ouvrant dans le domaine de la solidarité
de l'hébergement de l'insertion aussi
aujourd'hui encore tout à fait je suis
encore plus que jamais d'ailleurs nous
sommes en plein hiver et donc évidemment
nous sommes évidemment très sollicités
pour ouvrir des structures d'hébergement
d'urgence pour les personnes toutes les
personnes qui sont à la rue donc 7,7
c'est un métier très passionnant et très
prenant
mais nous sommes aussi évidemment très
mobilisé sur la question migratoire
politique de migration et je vous
avouerai qu'aujourd'hui les politiques
qui sont menées par le gouvernement
actuel à l'égard des personnes que l'on
appelle migrants mais que nous nous
préférons appeler exilés ou évidemment
en direction des personnes à la rue avec
toute cette politique en matière
d'hébergement d'urgence très très très
précaire ne nous rassure pas sur
justement
l'avenir de certaines personnes qui
aujourd'hui vivent des situations de
précarité très très compliqué mais je ne
suis pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui une faille
trier au sein de la pauvreté entre les
bons pauvres et les mauvais points
cet engagement professionnel et
politique qui doit beaucoup inquiété sur
votre vie personnelle votre famille le
vit plutôt bien
toute ma famille le vit plutôt bien j'ai
des personnes très compréhensive mois
après il s'agit juste voilà de trouver
aussi un petit peu de temps à consacrer
à sa famille mais ça c'est des choses
qui se gèrent assez tranquillement à
partir du moment où les personnes autant
de soissons bienveillante à l'égard de
l'engagement qui est le mien et qui est
un engagement assez assez aux
problématiques numériques ou c'est aussi
important
un dernier point que j'aimerais aborder
avec vous c'est cet engagement sur la
ville des clayes-sous-bois vous avez
toujours et d'y résider pardon
aux clayes-sous-bois c'est une ville que
vous connaissez bien eu quelques trous
mais c'est pas ce n'a pas été forcément
des trous de langue importance sur mon
absence os x
je suis chrétien depuis quasi plus de 30
35 40 ans maintenant c'est un engagement
de longue haleine c'est une ville que je
que je connais dans ses moindres recoins
et aujourd'hui certaines positions du
mien actuelle certaines positions de la
majorité actuelle ne me sied guère dans
le sens où je pense que nous sommes en
train de déséquilibrer ce qui faisait
l'harmonie de la ville jusqu'ici stade
c'est à dire d'avoir une population
mixte et nous sommes aujourd'hui en
train de réduire cette mixité notamment
en raison des projets urbanistiques qui
sont développés qui aujourd'hui sont
plutôt source de déséquilibre que de que
de rééquilibrage
j'en veux juste pour exemple le fait que
nous sommes cités pour la première fois
depuis l'application de la loi sru en
logement social et sur les aides
sociales
les obligations construction est tout à
fait c'est la première fois que la ville
de clayes-sous-bois été citée comme une
ville carence est fini car on sait ça
veut dire aujourd'hui qu'elle ne réalise
pas ses objectifs en matière de logement
social
et lorsque l'on sait que 70 % des
français sont éligibles au logement
social est que nous sommes les clayes
sous bois dans la moyenne nationale
là il ya réellement un gap qui est assez
important et qui ne permet pas
aujourd'hui au clae siens qui voudraient
vivre un parcours résidentiel au sein de
la commune de le vivre de manière
sereine et seront obligés de s'éloigner
ce qui aujourd'hui perturbe bon nombre
de
bon nombre de personnes et qui
perturbent aussi le développement de la
commune
un nouvel engagement pour ravir la
municipalité ne vous fait pas peur
qu'ils pensaient déjà
non j'y pense alors pas forcément tout
le temps en embrasant aujourd'hui ça va
mais une phrase pas tout le temps c'est
évidemment une chose auquel je pense
depuis depuis quelques temps j'ai un
genre discute avec mes amis de
l'opposition j'en discute avec mes amis
partenaires de gauche au sein de la
commune et plus évidemment puisque une
ville
comme les clayes-sous-bois ce n'est pas
simplement un mouvement politique mais
c'est aussi un mouvement avant tout
citoyen qui doit qui doit émerger qui
doit qui doit amener les propositions
pour pour la pour la conduire et
pourront pour développer un projet donc
c'est des choses évidemment auquel je
pense mais je devrai que nous sommes en
2018-2020 n'altère encore un peu loin et
6,6 il en espérant que
les élections ne soient pas ne soit pas
reporté nous sommes sur une sur une
échéance qui voilà qui est encore pas
forcément dans les têtes et dans la
structuration
très forte on bâtir victoire une
dernière question c'était 8 avril ce
sera la date du congrès du parti
socialiste vous allez le suivre avec
attention ce congrès oui tout à fait oui
bien sûr je suivrai avec attention ce
qui le rend ce qu'il en ressortira
j'espère simplement que l'ensemble de
mes amis et camarades anciens camarades
qui seront restés au sein du parti
socialiste ne seront pas déçus à l'issue
de celui ci et de l'inflexion qui sera
donnée ou non
2 de ce parti à l'issue de ce congrès
merci aux élus de saint quentin en
yvelines et des clayes-sous-bois
[Musique]
oui
et